[Music]
hey everyone this is bernard from berlin
germany
my question is about testing your
business ideas
so i've heard a bunch of people on your
podcast talk about this already and how
it's part of what made them successful
now i don't really understand what this
means testing your business ideas the
only thing i can think of is maybe
running multiple ads and comparing the
performance but beyond that i really
don't know what to do
so could you first of all tell me
how you have seen this done successfully
in the past and second of all how i can
become better at it thank you
all right the guy asked sean he said um
i hear you talk about testing ideas what
does that mean does that mean just like
running ads to like a page and getting
sales and the answer is yes that is away
but he wants to know about testing ideas
and how do you do that
all right so we can share a couple of
things that uh i think you talked about
this in the last one question friday but
the first is
customer conversations and the mom test
so the real there's a book called the
mom test worth reading uh if you want to
get better at the stuff but here's the
premise which is
talk to customers and your the rule is
don't make the mistake everybody does
don't pitch your product and just wait
for them to politely be like yeah sounds
really interesting let me know because
that's like a false positive you're only
allowed to talk to them about their
problem so you do what's called a
problem interview you just talk to them
about their life what they're you know
in their business whatever whatever your
area your products in you ask them
questions you try to see
a is this a real problem for them
uh b how big of a problem is it like
dude this is the biggest issue in my
life right now or uh it's nice to have
and you can suss that out by trying to
figure out okay so what have you done to
try to solve this and if they don't
really say anything well then it's
probably not actually that big of a
problem they haven't been trying to
solve it if they've tried like eight
solutions and none of it's working and
they're just banging their head against
the wall you know it's a real problem um
and so you try to figure out the problem
you try to figure out how big of a
problem and you try to figure out the
words they use to describe it as a
problem because that's what you're going
to use to create your solution and then
separately you could say
well
i'm working on a way to solve that it'll
be a xyz
are you interested in trying it and then
they say yes you say great
and then you make them pay some price
whether it's literally paid money or
give give your information or connect
your account so i can have your data or
whatever make them do something that has
some friction so you can gauge if
they're really interested or not that's
one way you could test an idea and
that's exactly what you did this weekend
we just talked about the basketball camp
thing that sean did you told me what the
idea was and he goes if you're if this
interests you then mowed me 1800 right
now and we all did and there was no
website there was nothing it was just a
phone call a text twitter thing and
that's the way i typically do things
oftentimes it'll take
maybe 20 or 30 calls
and i can probably get one person to
show interest but that's where a lot of
people fail is they actually don't talk
to enough people um so for my latest
thing i've actually talked to like 300
people
and um you have to talk to a lot of
people i invested in this one company
and they're trying to get customers and
i'm like well i'm gonna talk to you like
well we talked to like one person last
week and then the person the week before
i'm like oh dude it's got to be from
like 8 00 a.m to like 7 p.m and you're
on calls all day
um and that's
that that that way i think typically
works but most people don't have enough
intensity around it
there's another way which is you take a
preval pre-validated idea so you take an
idea that's already working and you just
put uh you change it in some way so oh
it's working in the u.s but there's no
version of this in europe
it's there's a pretty good bet that the
behaviors in the us are going to
translate to let's say europe or
wherever and so you can skip the
validation idea the validation point
that way i actually think validating an
idea is really really hard i actually
don't think you're ever going to get
this clear signal that like yep
check i know that people want this it's
just like a spectrum you're just
increasing your confidence level that
there's a reel there there but you're
never at 100
and until you you know many many months
in too far in the second thing is
another way to skip the line is just
work on something where you know you're
the customer because if you're the
customer for it i guarantee you on an
internet scale that there are at least
another hundred thousand people that are
just like you that have the same problem
as you that feel the same way you do you
may not be able to find them you may not
be able to market to them but they
definitely exist and so one way to
validate your idea is to just build
something that solves a problem for you
very rarely will that be too small where
it's only you or only you and 10 other
people that have that problem almost
always there's a huge group
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
and there's some times or a lot of times
like let's say like hubspot or some type
of software like riverside what we're
using now where it's like it's a little
bit challenging to get customers before
the thing is actually built and that
definitely exists and there's this
company that i talk to called zooper
z-u-p-e-r dot co and their headline is
power your field service and deliver a
better customer service basically it's
an app where if you're an electrician
all your electricians who work for you
they go out and they it's like time
tables and all this stuff and he was
like i was like how did you do this and
he said well i just
spent all my nights and weekends talking
to these business owners and i basically
kind of interned for them and i got to
know them really well and i honed in on
the problem very specifically and
i got like pre-commitments they didn't
pay me but they told me if i can do x y
and z they'll be my customer and so i
didn't validate it in the sense that i
collected money but i knew with a high
degree of certainty what the problem was
because i spent a year working with
these people and talking to them and
then when i built it it took about six
months to get my first customer and i
know another guy who did that uh al from
next health it's like a billion dollar
company now and he did the same thing he
built software for doctors and he goes i
quit my job and i became a secretary at
a doctor's office for six months to
learn exactly how they do things so i
knew very specifically the software that
i was building how it was going to solve
a problem and so i didn't validate it in
the sense that i collected money but
like i validated it in my mind of i had
a higher degree of certainty
so to summarize three ways that you can
validate your ideas
the worst way or the sort of least
fidelity way
go talk to as many customers you can go
nine to five go shadow them try to talk
to them about their problems figure out
how big of a problem it is and what they
do to solve it today the second uh you
know a higher fidelity way you actually
have an offer it's a landing page it's a
it's an ad it's a flyer it's an email
and you try to get people to pre-commit
to a solution that will also validate
that there's demand to this and then the
best way of all the ways is you know
there's demand because you have the
problem and if you have the problem you
know it well you know what solution
would work you have a place to test it
you can be patient zero and you can test
it on yourself and if you do all that um
you know you're not guessing do is this
problem real or not because you know
it's real
and all of these take a lot of courage a
lot of people don't do them because
they're afraid everyone's afraid you
just got to do it
and you can get done you can get a lot
done by just having some courage and
actually following these steps so
that's one question friday
[Music]
you